[Music]
and today and GameXplain we're going to
talk about and games and World
Championships that could have or did
change the way we know the world now so
let's start with this one between
Bronstein and Botvinnik now Bronstein
won the previous game the fifth game
against Botvinnik and was white and as
we can see white is about to grab some
ponds and Braunstein does take the first
one on age five age five rook takes h4
and that takes up six and now he's an
extra pawn up but what Vinick finds a
very very good plan here which will give
him enough counter play any ideas how
black can conjure up some play in this
fairly solid position now even though
black is material down he has very good
pieces he has an amazing Bishop on c6
hitting on both the a and E for upon
also rook is tying this rook to d4 so
black only needs to mobilize one more
piece to be close to balancing out the
position King b6 you play like what's
Vinick good job in b6 rook takes d6
how can we follow up
yes marching with the black king he five
and now Bronstein finds this really nice
move Ruby for he realizes that his
bishop will be much much stronger than
this Knight
that's just stranded on f6 rugby for
exchanges forced not g4 bishop takes a
four and now this bishop takes a four
was a reckless move because wide pass
pawns on e5 + f5 can be very dangerous
how can Bronstein mobilize these pieces
these pawns how can we mobilize this
these pawns he six yes correct
F takes c6 takes c6 no frosty didn't
take on e6 cuz that yes if EEP yes yes
he is preventing the black Bishop to
actually defend these squares so he has
to play Bishop e8 night King b3 b5 check
and now Knight h6 can get for f7 Bishop
takes f7 not f7 e for now let's take
stock well but Vinick is a piece down
which is not a great news for him
but he has a very very active a pawn but
Bronstein finds a very good resource in
this position which will actually be a
saving move for white
yes
Kings see - but the king comes then
black will also bring his own king and
most probably will have some problems
also the Aipom might start running as
well so Bronstein decided to defend
against this epon with his Knight
how did he do that if you bring your
Knight to d6 then they respond III and
you don't get there in time because even
if you take itto Knight c5 so instead he
played the paradoxical 98 because he
wants to head to d4 yeah so if you would
have done 96 III takes Knight c5 and
unfortunately black will not Queen which
would run into night d3 check but he'll
just play King III and white is just
that lost so he plays the paradoxical 98
because after e3 there's this knight a6
check so but Winnick here thought and
played III anyways but now there's two
options for white and now the tragedy
occurs because Braunstein most likely
saw that nighty six is possible but was
wondering if King c2 would work which
one should be play
the night check yes I believe this was
but I believe this was Bronstein's
original idea and after King every 94
here King a4e 2 takes takes this will
end in a draw because King B 6 takes
takes takes and draw and which would
have been an okay result for Bronstein
because he's a game up he won the
previous game but he started pondering
and thinking what if I bring my king to
see two and now it's black to move and
when tragically for white
if e to then King D - yeah but then I'll
stop you with kinky one yeah I'll just
come back with the knight and stop the a
pawn now if black King can reach the F
to square Y it is done for
if he goes King f3 then night II 6 and
Fe 2 then Knight d4 problem with King f3
is that the knight comes with check
no no so black is trying to promote the
epal black is trying to promote the e
pawn without getting into checks which
is not as easy as it looks
but but Vinick finds the way
kingi three exactly gets away from the
checks and if 96 no if King f2 then then
I just jumps to d4 just push the pawn
eat to King detain King f2 and sadly for
Bronstein he missed this idea of e to
pawn push first and now after King g3 he
just decided to resign but Bronstein got
another chance to win the game
no not this one and he was leading and
up a point in game 20 and gain 22 where
he was already leading again with a full
point is the same match and he came back
again and he was already in the lead by
this game like this point so he won game
22 and Bronstein was already leading but
when I quit one point so Botvinnik had
to win this game which is kind of tough
because the position looks pretty closed
pleased to me so white started a nice
night maneuver at night e2 Queen b6
Bishop c3 rook d8 and now white came up
with a brilliant Queen move in this
position
that is standard in these days but it
wasn't standard in the 50s white is
basically forcing an endgame Queen b3
now the idea is even though black could
take a takes this would open up the
position a little and eventually black
plays a6 rook FC one let's say 97 and
after Bishop f1 white will have two
plans one of them would be Bishop f8 93
to play B for a knight c5 or if let's
say black just waits y can start pushing
the pawn and play b4 and b5 opening up
the Bishop the position and getting a
stable advantage and now here black will
have to suffer a little for the draw so
obviously Bronstein would be happy with
a draw so he doesn't want anything to
happen 94
Queen takes b6 and Bishop e1 a very very
weird move but but Vinick and this was
actually one of the big themes of this
match he was always kind of banking on
the strengths of the bishop there while
Braunstein was using the Knights to have
some counter play but this time but
Winnick will be the one getting on on
top
so not a 593 defending everything first
he'll use the bishop pair later Bishop
f8 how can between ik try to untangle in
this position now what really doesn't
have too much space so he will need to
kick the Knights yes f3 exactly getting
rid of this nasty knight on e4
while all see also getting a little bit
of breathing space for the pieces 96
Bishop f2
she paid six Roxy one night see for
rookie one
so both Winnick first and foremost just
tries to coordinate his pieces first and
do action later Knight a5 King F one
Bishop g7 g for just taking away the f5
square knight c6 b3 what is b3 doing
yeah just keeping the Knights out and
also maybe hinting on some ideas of
Knight B to a for trying to getting
closer to that b6 pawn Knight b5 but
Braunstein not knows what to do and he's
trying to muddy waters and also at point
pointing out that he would like to plant
a knight on c3 if possible so King EE to
a4 chasing away the night so there won't
be not be four ideas
Knight c7 Bishop g3 and now out of the
sudden that very passive bishop that
started from e1 moves to g3 and puts a
lot of pressure on blacks position
already why they're slightly better in
this position 9a six bishop f1 f6 what's
the idea of f6 it's also very good move
yeah and also getting a firm grip on the
e5 square
apart from avoiding exchanges on e5 rook
D 195 rook takes rook takes e8 and now
but when it comes up with an idea that
is very unique and computers don't
really agree with him but I think what
Vinick was right when he executed this
idea he actually will make absurd upon
sacrifice the next move won't be upon
sacrifice but is connected with the idea
of upon sacrifice rook c1 yes rook takes
c1 night C 1 and in the long run but
Vinick is planning to bring the king to
c2 and then to move on forward after
that but black can play Bishop e3 King
the one Bishop takes King takes 93 King
C 295 and I would tend to agree that
both Winnick the bishop they're usually
and should be worth upon and he's
actually going to show that in this game
because we can see and see that these
nights on a 6 & a 5 are not doing too
much yeah they're kind of dumb one those
a 6 & a 5 squares also Knight c4 idea
doesn't really work because then because
then white would just take and then just
collect all the be pawns possible can
give 7 e 4 but the biggest problem for
black is that this night is completely
out of play and these bishops just keep
them in check
eternally yes
and tragically for Bronstein this is
also one of the critical games where he
should have held his own so he tries his
best
how can he try to build up a fortress on
which squares should be tried to build a
fortress with his pawns it's a tough one
I know but how can we try that well he's
okay with these pawns at the moment
Bronstein is because these Knights keep
the King away from attacking these be
pawns but lacks major concern are how to
defend the King side pawns from age 7 to
d5 so black needs to make a decision on
which color he will position his pawns
well in general black already has most
of his pawns on white squares so
continuing that seems very logical so he
played at 5 correct he's trying to build
up a white square blockade G takes G
takes a5 Bishop d3 well who would
exchange is favor in general in this
position
yeah normally white because white has
the bishop there
so naturally bronze team plays King g6
and tries to wait hoping that white will
run out of useful moves Bishop d6 a very
good move activating the bishop also
emphasizing how out of place this Knight
is on a six-night c6 Bishop b1 but he's
not in a rush because that can't really
do anything
also Bishop b1 hints on a different idea
what is the potential idea of this
should be one yes going to a two or even
taking taking and Bishop a two let's say
if black would play h5 might can already
capture on d5 and play Bishop a two and
if black loses that extra pawn it's
going to be over because those Knights
are helpless against those bishops so
very soon they'll see that black is
running out of moves can you have six
Bishop g3f take c4
like it's kind of realizing that that he
will have to defend the d5 and f5 points
simultaneously but it somehow doesn't
work because for example if black just
tries to wait eight six then white
played Bishop f4 the King would try to
go back it's the same deal ETA X eat
eggs Bishop a two or maybe even Bishop
d6 and after 97 Bishop d6 and black is
in deep trouble so Braunstein took even
though I'm sure you didn't want to have
takes e4 86 Bishop f4 h5 and how should
white continue in this position
h4e take Sita xh4 he took first but h4
is the main idea of this position
because black needs to have fixed
weaknesses and as I learned it from my
end game studies I know that if you want
to win an endgame your opponent at least
needs to have two weaknesses and we can
clearly see not just two but three
weaknesses these two pawns on d5 and h5
and also those terrible pawns on the B
line so Knight b8 Bishop g5 checking f7
Bishop f5 but Vinick is not letting that
b8 night out and now luck is in trouble
again because Bishop C it is an idea
chasing the night away also the black
King cannot move anymore because if King
g7 then Bishop e6 and the d5 drops and
if the King would move anywhere else
even Bishop g6 becomes an idea so Knight
a 7 which already looks very awkward
Bishop f4 knight c6 Bishop d3 a very
good waiting move black is basically
doomed to waiting and he can't really do
anything right now Knight c8 Bishop e2
King g6 Bishop d3 we should be to Bishop
f3 so Botvinnik is slowly slowly
grinding away and soon Braunstein is
running out of moves
97 Bishop g5 and Bronstein had enough
because suddenly those two knights are
tangled and cannot move because if the
knight moves why just takes on d5 and
otherwise black is just out of moves so
Braunstein decided to give it a day and
with this game but Winnick equalized and
in the last game Bronstein couldn't
conjure up any play and lost the match
to both Winnick yes this was his last
and only shot at the world title so
talking about drama this game between
Kasparov and Karpov was played in the
last game because Karpov won the
previous game to this one and was a
point ahead
so Kasparov had had to face a task to
win the game and retain the title
otherwise Karpov would have been the
world champion in 1987 so Kasparov just
took on c8 Knight takes c8 and it's
important to note that Karpov was in
time trouble at this moment
and according to Kasparov he was asked
by the arbiter to sign and ride the
moves so that's why he played the move
he played in this position but I'm
asking you what moves would you look for
in this position for white because this
was actually a very critical position
that could have decided the fate of this
match
Queen a1 is an idea to emphasize this
pin but the knight would just move away
to c5 yes and also it's important to
keep in mind that we are upon down so
why must take some action otherwise
you'll be a pawn down for nothing there
are the black pieces mostly centered at
on the Queen side so naturally you
should try to look for some other ideas
on the other side if our opponents
pieces are on the Queen side we should
look at ideas on the Kings side how can
we start bothering that lone King on g8
while also emphasizing that this a4 not
is a little bit out of place just for
the moment what piece is missing from
White's attack
the bishop cd4 doesn't really do much
apart from attacking the age seven
square yes
Bishop h5 is an idea but we're just
pushed upon but we really need some
supports to actually break through we
don't need pawns in this attack this
time we actually need some heavy heavy
artillery to actually break through
how can we emphasize that the a
four-night is a bit misplaced while also
hinting that we want to play around
blacks King side yes yeah yes so
Kasparov played Queen d1 which is good
gave some chances for Karpov but clean
b5 according to engines and afterwards
post-mortem analysis showed that Queen
b5 is even stronger according to the
engine Queen B 5 is kind of hard to deal
with because let's say King h7 knight c6
and now we can see that the black Queen
already needs to go to 8 Queen d3 check
f5 Queen d8 and we can see that blacks
position is pretty hopeless because all
of the white pieces are gaining so close
to the black king is going to be made
very soon so after Knight c5 Queen EA
twas an idea hinting at Bishop h5 Bishop
g6 stuff and black is on the verge of
losing but spire of plate Queen D 1
which is still a fine move gave black
the opportunity to play Knight c5 which
is actually a remarkable move which
works because Queen d8 engage 7 takes
there's a very nice resource here for
black
mm-hmm clean check and that just takes a
night and black would have been out of
danger but in time trouble it's
difficult to make call moves like Knight
c5 also this would this could only be
played if you realize that Queen Avon
penny five check is for certain playable
otherwise would be a pretty bad move but
Knight c5 was a saving move but Karpov
didn't see that he played 97 so how
should we continue here green da check
of course in gate 7
if check then black will play f5 yes and
that will not help our cause yes just
Knight takes f7 taking back the pawn and
now
Kasparov has a beautiful pawn structure
compared to car buffs and he will have
good chances of converting but it's
still a task not g6 Queen EA very very
good
positional move it's also hinting at the
idea of Bishop b4 so black has only one
move here
you can tell that this Queen on ei tis
rather annoying so like we'll need to do
his best to get rid of that queenie 7
yes cuz after queen takes a for Queen
takes up 7 as possible this should be
for putting the bishop in the center
King g8 in b5 now black is in trouble
because the b6 spawn cannot really be
defended
cuz Queen c7 would just drop the g6
night-night a fake mean takes b6
we have 6 min b5 notice them that
Kasparov will will start grinding slowly
he will not be in rush to prove the
advantage he knows that he's better and
near winning so he'll slowly grind away
Feeny 7 kingi to g6 maybe not the best
because the pawns should stay on the
black squares so for at least for a
while the bishop on e4 doesn't have a
target g6 Green a5 like his kind of
forced to wait green g7 Queen c5 green
of 7 h4 h5 now h5 maybe was a bigger
problem than g6 because g6 at least gave
some space for black but h5 might be a
little bit more premature mean C six
maybe seven Bishop d3 so why it is
planning to plant the bishop in c4 and
then to start pushing the e pawn before
Bishop c4 green check first asking where
is the black king going in d6 Bishop b5
also taking away some squares from the
night King g8 Bishop c6
'if five wouldn't be a bad move but we
don't we don't want to allow moves like
Queen B seven even if if they're not
winning
so Bishop c6 making sure there are no
tricks around being a seventh Queen B
for you C seven Queen B seven
but Karpov doesn't want the endgame be
five and now we can see that blacks
position is pretty much boxed in the
only thing white really needs to do is
to get a little bit closer and he will
be clinching the game and the match
green a5 Bishop I ate a splendid move
bringing the Queen closer to the claim
the Queen closer to the King Queen c5
queen of seven can gauge eight Bishop a4
and now basically the game is decided
because the black queen is kind of
stranded and will have to defend this
night on f8 eternally between d5 check
King h2 Queen c5 which should be three
Queen c8 and why only needs to take on
g6 and the game will be over
this should be one Queen c5 King g2 and
black resigned now black could try Queen
d5 Bishop f3 in c5 Bishop b4 Queen B 4
and now we must pay attention can we
take on g6 at this moment
does Bishop think g6 work
obviously black will need to take on g6
queen takes g6 should black resign in
this position
Queen to g4 then white can start
checking and running out but isn't the
black king out of moves so there's this
trick of Queen b7 f3 boom Queen takes f3
and stalemate so obviously even in
winning positions it's important to keep
your guard up between before so white
would play f3 first and if Queen B 2
that will be the last check because
after King h3 Queen B for black is just
going to lose slowly because black will
slowly run out of moves in this position
and after
this luck has just lost my can go just
g4 or ya black black will be slowly
running running out of moves of g4 and
likes so after King g2 Karpov resigned
and Kasparov retained his title a very
good performance by Kasparov winning a
game that had to be one otherwise he
would have lost his title so talking
about decisive and very important and
games calls and anon comes to mind so
this one was in the middle of the match
and it was pretty important for that
World Championship match as the score
was even at this moment 97 Bishop f4
takes takes well if you took take a look
at this position who would you say is
better yeah why should be better because
of more space and also because of other
assets what are their assets yes
why does the bishop pair so in general
should be better the game continues with
age for cousin's trying to gain some
more space also hinting at ideas of
attacking the g7 pomp b6 h5 h6 castles
should be 7 Luke d3
yes yes
so the rook is actually heading to g3
attacking the g7 C 5 boogy boogy 8
Bishop d3 so Carlson is in hurryin is
immediately attacking a nun's position
but anons is ready for this and
patiently starts defending we should be
three g 6h takes Knight takes g6 now
cousin could take on g6 but that would
lead to oppose it colored bishops and
that would give big chances for black to
hold
so obviously cousin is not interested
Luke h5 so he defends the e5 pawn bishop
c6 Bishop c2 so cousin is slowly like
the style of Botvinnik we saw earlier
slowly trying to grind away King b7 from
G for a 5 we should be one defending all
of his pieces we should be one group d8
Bishop c2 Ruby g8 and plays King D - and
now this could have been a turning point
for the whole match because now Anand
has a great choice that he misses
it's black to move and change the whole
evaluation and maybe even chess history
if he finds this move
yennai takes pawn and if rook takes
King d3
now black will need to find one more
precise move yes yes not be to check
here and after work to xg8
it would have been anand on the top and
pressing he's up upon and most likely
cousin would have need to suffer in this
position to try to hold which is not
entirely clear if possible but Knight
takes e5 was missed by Anand and in fact
a4 was played almost immediately after
cousin played King d2 a great great save
not not really a great save but a very
lucky moment for cousin because Knight
takes e5 would have been very dangerous
night King king he - but much to the
credit to cousin he still starts to play
and continue with his grind even after
such a setback of seeing this Knight
takes e5 idea and falling for that
kingi to a3 f3
just making sure no more tricks are
allowed
he bolsters this rook on g4 and defends
his position with f3 rook the 8th King
he won again getting out of all tactical
ideas rook d7 Bishop c1 just putting
pressure on this e3 pawn also hinting on
the h6 one ok 8 king he to patiently
getting forward moving forward with his
pieces Bishop a4 this should be 4 check
why does not interested in exchanging
those beautiful bishops bishop things g6
and only does when he runs upon rook
takes g6 Bishop a4 rook takes c6 but
already white is winning a lot of pawns
so black is very close to losing
Bishop takes a three okay one King III
Bishop C to check and black resigned
because after let's say King a six rook
takes h6 black will be just too many
pawns down so this was a great great
example of how one move one little slip
could have changed everything and I want
to finish with one last on on Carson
game again in this game cousin is white
and this was an important game in his
set in their second match Knight f6
Castle 94 and honestly what would we
expect cousin to play in this position D
for a rookie one
your first instinct was right
rookie 1 we would expect cause them to
play rookie one but not in this game
cause and goes for the full point with
the very principled e4 straight into the
Berlin 96 takes takes and we head into
the Berlin defense that everybody loves
age three Bishop d7 Knight c3h6 and now
Carlsen as usual chooses a harmonic way
of developing his pieces how can we
develop our pieces in this position with
white
rook d1 is one way of playing but the
other very classical way of playing
these positions is b3 fianchetto the
bishop King c8 Bishop b2 c5 rook d1
naturally Carlson's Knight is headed to
d5 d6 rook e1 just bringing his pieces
closer to the center 95 g5 how can we
stabilize this knight on d5 c4 of course
King b7 King h2
now this King age to move is a very
crafty one from Carlsen
he's kind of getting ready of playing g4
because if he would play g4 now 97 King
gauge 2 would run into this idea of h5
at moments King gauge 2 therefore and
could run into h5 ideas at moments
therefore he plays King age 2
immediately
so when he plays g4 he can already move
his King to g3 a5 a4 stopping all funny
business on the Queen side
97 g4 so after night g6 he can bring his
King to g3 already Bishop e7 and now
cousin finds a plan to occupy the f6
square for his Knight how does he do
that in this position
naturally this knight on d5 is fairly
comfortable so we'll need to find a way
to position the other night on f6 yes
yes a great plan by cousin which
actually makes it harder for black to
move in in this game
rook the 894 Bishop f8 Knight f6 and
already Carson has a little bit of a
grip on blacks position it's by all
means playable for black but that knight
on f6 is very annoying b5 an amazing
tactical idea by Anand his plan is if
white would take on b5 a4 would be
played so he played Bishop c3 but if 8x
b5 a4 has played BAE takes rook takes
and this rook would be majestic on this
a line also putting a lot of pressure on
the white pawns
so this ship c3 trying to keep the
position close B takes B takes King c6
King f3 coming closer kind of preparing
f4 idea for later rook b8 guinea for a
rogue b4 so Ananda's deserve praise for
his creative play in this game and will
be 4 is a magnificent idea Bishop takes
before and which pawn would be take
normally da yes and actually that would
have been a good move but anon got
carried away with his creative play and
actually in this position black could
even be better because there's a lot of
pressure on these pawns on a4 and maybe
soon on c4 so it would have been a
full-fledged fight after a takes but he
took on C he took let's see in our
cousin finds the only way to create some
play for white
f/4 doesn't work at the moment because
black would just sake and we wouldn't
want to exchange off this beautiful
knight on d5 so cousin finds a different
plan
rook f1 mm-hmm but Brooke f1 f4 will
still have to take with the d5 Knight
and that's what we really don't want to
do yeah
not age five exactly that's what Magnus
played he wants to take with a knight so
king b7 f4 and it's very admirable how
he plays this position with such
ambition and it's very important to note
when we will see how he will actually
win this position with active play G
takes Knight takes f4 takes takes Bishop
takes e4 but the point was to actually
attack on the seventh rank and play rook
d7 yeah yes so now the rooks are
actually very useful in the center ok
695 cutting the support of the f7 pawn
and that's kind of a bad news for or not
yes rook c6 otherwise if he would have
played Bishop e6 one that it would be
very passive the other one is that after
takes F takes rook c1 black will be
really passive and most likely will lose
the game cuz after like rook c8 h for
the pawn will be very fast so roque 695
cutting off the support for the f7 pawn
rook c6 rook takes f7 Bishop c5 and now
cause them to play and win
you can already have a feeling of
something happening on the sea line
because there's way too many pieces just
stranded there like four of them how
could cause and use this fact to his
benefit
now the big defender in this position
for black is the rook on c6 if we could
remove that somehow that would make our
day much better that is my cousin took
on c7
yes rook takes e7 Knight takes c7 King
c6 and anon cannot afford to take on c7
because then the rooks see one idea
suggested would work with full effect
because everyone is pinned on the sea
line and if you move the c4 Bishop I'll
take on c5 if you play King b6 I take on
c4 and this is a trivial win for white
so King c6 Knight b5 calls and defends
the night also if black would take on b5
that will just still fat hastened his an
available loss and after East 6 b3 King
Day 3 they should be 7h for a for g5
those pawns are just too fast and after
age takes a sticks 8 we cousin is not
afraid of ghosts plays King c3 if King B
if B 2 then just king c2 or b3 any of
those and these pawns are stopped and
and the white pawns just promote
therefore after king sees me black
resigned and calls and retained his
title by winning this Berlin and gay
[Music]